trust and treaty obligations that we
cannot have the kind of prosperity among
the tribal nations that they deserve so
we start there and I think what I would
like to see I hope I hope this is the
right way to think about it and I we've
stayed very open textured in how we've
we've addressed our plan we've not yet
gone to statutory language because we
invite much more conversation from our
tribal leaders from the inter tribal
organizations from experts and young
people who want to come in and tell us
about different parts in the language
but here's where I'd like to start I
would like to start with the United
States government honoring its current
trust and treaty obligations in full and
see how far that gets us if I can I just
want to add one more small point because
it's something else that Deb and I have
worked on together and that is about
bigger programs and plans that will
reach a lot of people they're not
specific to Indian country but would
have a profound effect I've proposed to
tax a 2 cent tax on the greatest
fortunes in this country it's a wealth
tax the top one-tenth of 1% and with
that two cents we can fund childcare for
every baby in this country age zero to
five that means money straight down into
our tribal nations to be able to offer
this care for every one of their
children paid for by the federal
government universal pre-k for every
three-year-old and four-year-old in this
country raising the wages of every
childcare worker and preschool teacher
in this country these are the things we
do and should be doing together and I'll
just add because it gives you an idea
of how distorted our economy has come
become that same two cents will not only
do all of that for our babies it will
permit us to provide technical school
community college four-year college all
of our tribal colleges tuition free
expand the Pell grants for the people
who most need them put fifty billion
dollars into our historically black
colleges and universities minority
serving institutions and tribal colleges
and cancel student loan debt for ninety
five percent of the folks who've got it
this gives people a lot of educational
opportunities and also means for people
struggling now with student loan debt we
can cancel that student loan debt and
that's going to make it easier for a lot
of people to be able to move back to the
reservation be able to move back to
small towns and rural America you ought
to be able to make it wherever you live
in America and part of that is about the
United States government honoring its
promises that's where I am on this
[Applause]
bouzouki walk at your condition to Cosmo
magazine autumn vomiting and doncha
banish nabe Ojibwe to me now I serve as
the president of the United Church of
Michigan vice president for Midwest
alliance of sovereign tribes and first
vice president for the National Congress
of American Indians in addition to being
chairperson of the Sesay Murray travel
ship why unions
oh I want to thank mr. chairman I want
to thank you immediately after you were
elected you've always been a friend to
Indian country and you came to our NCI
Executive winter session reception and
I've seen you there every year since so
you have supported Indian country not
just because you're running for election
for president but you've been around
since you've been elected so I
appreciate and thank you for the warm
welcome you've always given me I
appreciate it and so we did we had a
conversation at that reception and you
told me I asked you a little bit about
your personal history because of the
attacks during the campaign by that that
centerfold guy that you ran against hood
and I don't remember his name anymore
Scott Brown maybe or something and you
told me your personal story in a very
personal level and and I urged you to
tell your story and I appreciate that
you did and what I would say is from
here forward because now we're in a
presidential election that we take
Michelle Obama's advice and when when he
goes low you go high and when he attacks
in a racist way disparaging one of our
heroes one of our female Indian hero
women in our country that you take the
option not to give any credence to his
his racist arguments but instead tell us
what you're going to do for us the
cabinet position that you've proposed is
amazing that's history in the making I
appreciate
president obama got the ball rolling
with the annual tribal leader conference
i would ask that you changed that the
tribal leaders summit we have not had
one since the current presidents
occupied the White House so I'm excited
about the leadership that you're gonna
bring to the White House and the
government-to-government relationship
that I know you will instigate how you
will institutionalize for tribes natural
resources extraction on tribal land on
treaty lands threaten sacred sites
cultural resources tribal sovereignty
and the environment the health of entire
tribal community suffers when outside
companies extract precious resources
from tribal communities and in turn
share none of the profits tribes are
forced to shoulder the risk of the
disaster but share none of the wealth
tribal lands are treated as wastelands
for industrial mining uranium mining
fracking and pipelines how will your
administration ensure tribal governments
are consulted and tribal leaders
exercise authority over all natural
resource extraction and travel nations
thank you thank you for the question so
let me start by saying tribal
governments are the ones who should
control what happens on tribal lands
that's what it means government to
government relationship the second part
I will revoke the permit for the
pipelines
[Applause]
but the third part is again to think
about structural change not just where
we make one difference because we must
the pipeline permit should not have been
issued in the first place we can revoke
that and straighten it out but much
better not to make mistakes to begin
with
so here's what I want to do differently
I want to say on all federal lands all
lands near tribal reservation lands that
it is the tribes who are not just
consulted but who actually have to make
an informed decision and they are
decision makers before the federal
government goes forward with actions on
other federal supports Indian country
sovereignty that supports our
initiatives and we are very fortunate to
have her in our corner as it is but
it'll be far more advantageous for
Indian country to have her as this next
president of the United States
my issue is of sovereignty
responsibility and self-sufficiency so
what we wanted to do is find out with
the United States Trust obligations and
treaty responsibilities as president how
do you plan to fulfill the federal
obligation of trust and treaty
responsibilities so thank you for the
question I think this goes to what we've
been talking about all morning and that
is the government-to-government
relationship between the federal
government and the tribal nations and
that's a true resetting of the
relationship it is there in words but
not in action the difference is that we
need to change the rules to make sure it
is there in action as well I can do part
of that from the White House there is
much I love saying this that a president
can do by herself and I commit to do
that but there is also much that we have
to work with Congress on and this is why
I'm so excited about the work that I'm
doing with congresswoman Holland and why
it's so important that she's there
undertaking this issue with each of our
colleagues holding them accountable
forcing them to vote over and over and
over on issues that address this basic
nation-to-nation relationship
thank you this is how we work together
the importance of land and the
importance of land as a piece of both
autonomy history and respect and so I
strongly we've we've been in these
battles side by side protect and as
president will protect the lands that
belong to the tribal nations Harvey got
one from Lumbee tribe
so I'm Harvey Godwin chairman of the
Lumbee tribe from North Carolina and
it's southeastern and it's royal and
yeah and we've been through two
hurricanes in the last three years and
still recovering from that but today I'd
like to talk to you about something a
little bit different the Lumbee tribe of
North Carolina receives funding through
the Native American housing and
self-determine Act known as no hasta
underhood in 2008 the Housing and Urban
Development Veterans Affairs supportive
housing program was initiated called HUD
Vash the Lumbee tribe was awarded 20 HUD
Vash vouchers as a part of our tribal
HUD Vash demonstration program to
provide housing to American Indian
veterans living in our territory who are
homeless or at risk of being homeless as
of today with the collaboration between
the Lumbee tribe Veterans Affairs Office
and the Veterans Administration in
Fayetteville North Carolina which is
home to Fort Bragg in the 82nd airborne
the tribe has housed 20 Lumbee and other
native homeless veterans with a waiting
list of 22 more we are waiting
additional bachelors to hood so Senator
Warren what can you currently do in
Congress or what would you do is the
President of the United States of
America to fully fund and push through
the Congress the needed funds to ensure
that not one Native American is without
dignified housing as Native American
veterans thank you
now this question you raised it's one
that is very close to me personally all
three of my brothers served in the
military my oldest brother was career
military the other two served and then
came out one more construction after one
started a little business when it
doesn't work out started another one my
three brothers are still very close to
they all live back in Oklahoma now and I
don't think there's a phone conversation
or visit that goes by that one of the
other of them doesn't raise the issue of
how our government treats its veterans
our veterans are our military active
duty military have agreed to lay down
their lives for us their families
sacrifice enormous Lee I can still
remember when I was just a little girl
and my mother every day would run to the
mailbox to see if there was a letter
there for Don read one from John maybe
one from David and on the days when
there were no letters from any other
boys she'd say well maybe tomorrow maybe
tomorrow and on days when there were
letters lit up the family lines called
everybody read the letter readied again
she met my daddy at the edge of the
front yard got a letter today from one
of the boys when people sign up for
military service and agree to give up so
much that's a sacred promise with the
United States government and that means
we have to honor our promises to our
veterans our promises for health care
our promises for education and our
promises for housing there should be no
homeless veterans in this country none
I also believe that supporting the
tribal nations to be able to help with
the homeless veteran problem is is
exactly the right way for the federal
government to go but once again the
problem is it doesn't work if it's all
words and no money you've got to be
willing to put real money behind it I'll
keep pushing I know others in toppers
like Deb will keep pushing on this we
will keep fighting for this but I
guarantee you this how we make real
change is we've got a president who's
willing to fight for it and people
across this country who are ready to say
it is time for the federal government to
do what's right in this nation and our
last question is amber Torres for Walker
River pjo wah wah wah me amber Torres
mean onion oh I've gotta cut a point of
II know a guy way
good morning everybody my name is amber
Torres I'm the chairman for the Walker
River Paiute Tribe insurers Nevada and I
thank you for coming this morning so the
question that I have for you this
morning is regarding voting rights in
2016 Walker river Paiute Tribe and
pyramid lake paiute tribe set the
standard for equal access to voting
rights in the our tribal citizens on the
reservations in the United States my
question to you will be if you're
elected as the president how would you
ensure that all Native Americans on
reservations have the same access
without having to litigate
thank you let's let's just start with a
statement of our values voter
suppression is democracy suppression and
it must go the idea that one of the
major political parties in this country
intends to retain power by keeping
American citizens from voting is
appalling and we need to be willing to
fight back against that in all places
where it shows up it is a special
problem I know on on the tribal
reservation lands and in particular I
support both repealing the suppression
acts but satellite voting to give more
people access I think this is one of the
areas once again where it's got to be
done in concert needs are different in
different areas but the key has to be
you've got to be willing to put money
behind it it's not enough simply to say
okay everybody can do this but there's
no money so polling places get closed
people can't make it the distances get
further and the state government that's
running it says gee we don't have any
money to make this happen so I have you
would be surprised I got a plan I'm
making sure that every American citizen
gets a chance to vote and to get that
vote counted but a big part of it is to
set federal standards for access to
voting make sure that those federal
standards are appropriate to individual
regions and individual locations and
that there's real money to back it up
voting is the heart of our democracy and
we have got to be willing to protect it
as a nation
thank you I know senator Warren has to
leave and please a round of applause for
the panel
[Applause]
I'll look into this I'll learn more what
an interesting idea
so can I learn it more about this all
right